It's spooky in here!
I've got really big glasses today.
You like my glasses?
Well, today I might be a bit of a clown, so...
How about princess?
to dance with the devil?
Yeah.
Wait, hold on.
Let me adjust my...
My mic is always falling.
Like, it's always...
The mic stand is always wanting to move around.
Hello!
We are back.
Half-Life 2.
Hi!
I was like, oh, I should play more Half-Life.
And I was like, why do I feel so hesitant about it?
And I was like, oh, I remember.
where I left off.
And then I was like, well, I'm going to watch.
I'm going to watch a how-to video, like a Let's Play.
I'm going to watch a Let's Play.
And what I saw really made me mad.
So I'm going to try it and see if it works.
I was like...
Huh?
Let's play The Ancient Texts.
Yeah.
For real.
Oh my gosh, Torgo!
Thank you for the peek!
Watch the fantastic reality Vaughn.
You're amazing!
You're singing, dancing, stage prizes!
Ah, thank you!
Pinned a link for non-Twitter folks.
Oh, I was going to post about it on YouTube.
Community.
I don't have the link on me right now, but I was going to post it.
I will do that another stream.
Thank you, though.
Thank you.
Um...
But don't listen too hard because my voice was...
was pretty rough.
Yeah.
But, um, yeah, I watched the thing.
I'm gonna try and do it.
You can do it.
Cheese that room.
It seemed like a cheese.
So...
I get hit by tariffs for all the MGS merch.
Yeah.
I did.
Open your Half-Life series.
Thank you!
I bought a bunch of Metal Gear acrylics.
But I'm excited because I'm going to open two of them.
Okay, so they sold acrylics of almost every character from 1, 2, 3, 4.
Peace Walker, and V.
I didn't end up buying any of from V because I felt I was already going a little insane.
But you could buy boxes of each of the games as well.
And I'm pretty sure boxes have one of each character.
They should, no?
I don't know how gotcha works, to be honest.
But...
Um...
I think it depends.
But, um...
When I was purchasing them, they had run out of boxes for Peace Walker and 4.
So I had to buy those individually.
I bought 10 of them individually.
So...
Um...
That's true gotcha.
And I will unbox them on stream.
Hmm.
10 Huey incoming.
I know!
But the other ones Might be okay Yeah, yeah, yeah I think I watched your set in the VOD About three times now Looks so good You think so?
Thank you Thank you of the prison What is your wisdom?
Don't use a spoon
Yeah, I imagine for For Peace Walker I'll get all Hueys And for four I'll get all Naomi's Yeah, I imagine Spank, thank you.
Oh, I got my big lashes.
Got my new credit card today, Minky.
No!
Oh my gosh, sulking.
Please be responsible with your money, okay, everybody?
Please be financially responsible.
Anyway, um, uh, what was I gonna say?
Oh, before I start, I do want to say, wait, the box sets are also on Ami-Ami.
Description says all types can be collected by purchasing one box.
Oh, wait, they're on Ami-Ami-Ami too?
Oh, wait, it's a good thing I didn't get it on Ami-Ami because they stopped shipping for it now.
My Koharu, actually, my Koharu, I got a Koharu, um, desk mat and...
um she's i don't know where she is she got shipped shortly after all this happened so i don't know where she is it has no shipping no shipping what's it uh tracking on it so um she might be gone forever somewhere koharu on holiday in the middle of the ocean maybe uh she's in the twilight zone probably have faith okay
okay you aren't the boss of us boss boss thank you so much for the peek okay tell me what to do I'm telling you, I'm your mom.
I'm also your mom, Dr. Doak.
I'm your mom.
Minke donations don't impact my livelihood.
That's very good to hear.
Thank you.
Seeing Minto and Freeman's outfit in the thumbnail art makes me wonder how she'd look in Samus' zero suit.
I'm about to fight the end.
I'm following your way of non-lethal all the way.
Let's go!
Get the camos that way.
I'm feeling...
I'm not gonna lie.
I'm feeling not burnt out over half-life.
But I'm ready to beat the...
I'm ready to get the game.
I'm ready to be done with the game.
I think maybe...
Maybe last time because I wasn't feeling so well.
I have a bit of a sour taste.
I'm ready to move on to another game.
It's been five parts now.
but um i don't know i don't know if i'll finish today or if one more i guess we shall see i kind of have to be up early ish tomorrow because i will be having meet and greet at vexpo so kobats it's your birthday no request for a nyaruko humming just want to say thanks for liking my good morning minto flower post sometimes yeah thanks for posting them they're so sweet.
Happy birthday, combat!
Happy, happy birthday.
Gonna be a long one if you want to finish.
I think I looked it up.
There's four more chapters.
But it really depends on if they are so long or not.
Maybe probably just one more stream than after this.
What do you think of Half-Life so far?
I really do like it.
I really do.
I am having a lot of fun with it, so.
As credit starts to roll, Gabe rolls out.
And to announce Half-Life 3 button, covered in inches of dust.
And also, before I start, I have a little something, a little treat I want to try.
I'm doing a taste test on stream of Werther's original.
But it's not like the granny so much.
Oh my gosh, wait, this is stuck.
It's caramel, but it's pumpkin spice flavored.
Oh, but it's really gooey.
It's like stuck to the paper.
Wait, it's like really...
It's really stuck.
Okay, good thing Grandma's not eating this.
Her dentures would fall out.
Or anybody with veneers.
Oh my gosh.
Can people with veneers have gum?
Hmm.
I just finished playing through Half-Life 2 to remember.
gonna tell you the feeling of wanting to be done doesn't go away cheese at every chance i don't know how to cheese in the game half-life one and two are both from an era when we couldn't move on to another game nearly as easily as now so they definitely drag on a bit more that is so fair actually though that's very fair i oh yeah there's so much
There's so much on the paper.
It's really yummy.
It's not hard to chew at all.
It's very soft.
It's caramel.
It's really soft.
I recommend it.
It's yummy.
Mmm.
I recommend it, but maybe freeze it or something.
It's like, oh, it's really super soft.
I think I'm going to choke on this.
It's like a super soft caramel.
Oh.
I mean, it tangled me.
Yeah, I think after this, there was four more chapters, so I guess it really depends on...
I think we'll do two streams.
I don't want to rush it either at the same time.
You know, I don't want to, like...
Wait, am I in mid?
Wait.
Are they coming or...
Wait, why is this guy here?
Am I...
Mid-mission?
Also, when I watch that tutorial, it should...
Ow!
The caramel is in my teeth and it hurts!
You know when it's, like, so sweet in your teeth?
Uh-oh, I hope I don't have cavities.
That would be one hell of a way to...
To find out on stream.
Okay, so basically what they did was they did this.
was they wait I think wait I don't remember which one they put it in wait I don't remember which I think they stood in this one
look at all these health packs holy moly okay so they did this and then okay but you gotta put this one in here.
Wait, how much way does it face?
Okay, like that.
And then they stood in this one, and then they put this one.
Is this backwards?
Oh, yeah, it's totally backwards.
Just a little bit more, like that.
Maybe?
Okay.
And then they did this one.
But let's put all this in here.
And I just...
I just chill in here.
And then sometimes...
I get...
Sometimes I...
Maybe we'll be okay.
I don't know.
Okay, I have to do this last one fast, I think.
I'm scared, though.
I'm scared.
I'm gonna save.
Okay, I saved now.
And then we'll do this last one.
Okay.
Save for the setup.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Way ahead of you.
First time it took me a few hours to get through this section.
Last time, like 10 minutes.
Okay.
I think if I use the grab gun on the...
What are those called?
The things that fly and slice and dice you.
I can't remember for some reason.
um is the left one backwards yeah it's not this one is set up this one is set up this one is not set up yet the man hacks yeah yeah yeah this is probably the hardest part of the game oh my gosh you can use grab gun on grenades too oh i will try to remember that thank you that's actually really helpful i think and then sometimes i think we need to leave and shoot maybe the guys up there
I'm nervous right now.
Because I don't know if I'm gonna set it up in time properly.
I'm scared, okay.
Okay.
Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
Be fine trust.
Okay, I'm gonna save them.
Oh.
Uh, get in there.
Get in there!
Get in there properly, please.
No, please, please, properly.
Okay, please, properly.
Please, properly.
Okay, oh my gosh.
Here we go.
Theoretically, I should be fine.
Just here.
I don't know if my one on the left is working properly.
Oh, gosh.
Theoretically.
Hold!
Should I try another candy?
More soldiers.
Wait, that was so fast.
Already?
Wait, what?
I hear them.
Okay.
It's working.
Wait.
Did I hear a manhawk?
It's working?
More soldiers are coming, Gordon.
It's working!
The AFK strike!
Does
something fall?
I can't, yeah, I don't know.
I've hit a mother load of soldiers.
They're coming in from everywhere.
I feel like I should save.
Oh,
something hit me.
I'm not quite sure what.
We lived.
Stubbed toe?
Minus eight shield reset.
Okay, Gordon, I'm going to leave off here.
and catch up with you.
Be there as soon as I can.
Wait, was that a grenade?
No.
Was that it?
It was not.
Survive the second turret standoff.
Wait, there's more?
Gordon!
Oh!
Um...
Sorry to take so long, Gordon.
Gordon looks like you could have used some help.
I won't leave you again though No, let's track down Mossman.
I did save.
I'll save again.
Oh My god I don't remember what what video I saw on YouTube.
I don't remember who it was but good golly.
I could kiss him
What the hell?
Thank you for the gifted!
Thank you, Winter.
Oh, my stinking god.
I thought I was going to be fighting for my afterlife in here.
I thought it was going to be the worst time ever.
And that was it.
No, guys, it was me.
You're welcome.
I made that.
video.
Oh, what did I...
What did I just do?
Okay.
Actually, let's go back to my shotgun.
And there's more here!
They were like, you're gonna have a bad time.
Absolutely cheesed it.
Thorne, welcome to membership!
I should re-title my stream How to Get Away.
How to do this chapter.
Easy mode.
No issues at all.
You're not going to leave me, right, Alex?
Look at her.
She looks ready to fight.
What are you looking at?
His shifty eyes.
Uh-oh.
Oh my god, there's so many of them.
Oh my god.
Is there anything I can take?
Brutal.
They're still alive.
Maybe I shouldn't have used my shotgun.
Okay.
So I started blasting.
Maybe I underestimated how many guys were going to be there.
Maybe I thought it would be like three.
Wow.
Look how old that computer is.
Great.
Another security station.
Oh no.
Are we gonna do that whole thing again?
Huh.
All fire modes, yeah.
Oh, nice.
Uh-oh.
Well, come on, Gordon.
We don't want to keep her waiting.
Okay.
Where are they coming from?
Whoa.
I'm here!
Don't yell at me!
Let me seal this door.
Yeah.
Seal it?
Alright, nice.
Oh, okay.
Wish I could have gotten the help.
There she is.
Leave it talking to me, Gordon.
Wait, where are you?
I'm not good with words.
Hello?
Oh, thank God somewhere.
Alex?
Gordon, how did you get in here?
We know all about you and Brain.
Yeah.
You've been a spy for the Combine the whole time.
Damn it.
Move back, Mosman.
We're coming in.
Alex, whatever you may think, I assure you I have worked to protect your father.
Shut up and be glad you're still some use to us.
We're going to reconfigure this teleport and get the hell out of here.
You see, we're working to the same end.
I've already reprogrammed the modulator to emulate a Zen relay.
That's my father's work, you stole.
It's my work, too.
And I had to prove to Dr. Brain that your father would be the most valuable member of any research effort going forward.
Enough of your bullshit!
Where's my dad?
I'm going to bring him in.
Oh, in here?
You sound Eli?
No thanks to you.
Just enter the coordinates for Dr. Kleiner's lab and let's get moving.
Uh oh.
But we need access to the teleport platform and we're locked out.
I'll take care of that.
They're not gonna come in though.
Okay, let's go.
What's in here?
Whoa!
Oh
This fight is tough.
Oh, okay.
I'm prepared.
I'm not prepared.
I'm I'm not prepared.
It looks like it's waiting for us The combine use a peculiar pulse forming network with a very long rise time takes quite a while to recharge So you've warmed it up for us good and just in is it her gonna kill her?
Dad, down here.
Papa!
Sorry we took so long.
I hope that wasn't too bad for you.
Don't worry about me, sweetheart.
Judith!
I see they set you free.
Not exactly.
Eli, I was so worried about you.
The coordinates, Dr. Mossman.
The coordinates.
So, this is the combine.
This looks so fun.
I want to be in there.
Hurry up, Mossman.
I brought one of the turrets.
Yes, Alex.
Where are you?
We're in Noah Prospect.
Oh, Super Chat, what?
Are you ready for us?
Noah's Six Flags ride.
Ready, willing, and fully enabled.
Good.
We'll send my dad through first.
He's in position for...
Uh-oh.
What's that?
Hold on, gotta bring this back down.
Yo!
Stop!
What are you doing?
I'm sorry, Alex.
It's the only...
No!
What's going on, Alex?
Is something coming through?
Or...
Are we in trouble?
Dr. Kleiner, you have to stop them.
Oh my god.
Gordon, what coordinates are these?
Where the hell did she take him?
Uh-oh.
No.
Cover me, Gordon.
Oh.
I've got to reset the portal.
Okay.
Gordon, use the turrets.
Use turrets?
Where?
Oh, over there.
Where do I put them?
I
don't know where they're going to come from.
Ah!
Oh, shoot.
Hi.
Don't don't ain't not at me.
Where are they going to come from?
All through there?
Oh, man.
Oh my god!
Over here too!
I'm trying!
Okay, ma'am.
I'm trying, I'm trying!
Can she die?
Can she die in this part?
I'm scared.
So maybe not this guy.
Oh, she can!
Okay.
Oh my gosh.
Please.
Where
did that guy come from?
Uh, you're telling me.
Okay, so there are guys coming from over there.
Okay, good.
Watch the turrets!
Oh my gosh, oh my gosh.
Oh, good job, good job, team.
Uh...
Almost?
Okay, are you sure?
We sure?
We sure about that?
Where is he?
Oh, there it is.
Get his ass!
Okay, let's go!
I'm waiting on you!
Can we go?
I'm in, I'm in!
Oh my god,
we made it!
My god, we made it.
Oh my god, we made it.
Where's Dr. Kleiner?
Dr. Kleiner, let us out!
Uh-oh.
I don't think that's Dr. Kleiner.
Alex?
Gordon?
My god, how did you get here?
And when?
What's wrong?
My dear, I...
I had given up hope of ever seeing you again.
I was afraid we might not make it either.
I think the teleport exploded just as we were porting out.
Indeed, it did.
Take his gun.
Reproductions were felt far and wide, but that was over a week ago.
What?
Gordon and I were just there a minute ago.
Fascinating.
We seem to have developed a very slow teleport.
Whoa.
This suggests an entirely new line of investigation.
A week?
Then what have we missed?
A great deal, my dear.
Oh, gosh.
The blow you struck at Nova Prospect was taken as a signal to begin the uprising.
But what about my father?
Well, that is most troubling.
According to the Vortigants, he is a prisoner at the Citadel.
We've got to get my father out.
We've just got him out of jail.
And another of your friends arrived several days ago.
Yeah?
Dog!
You made it!
Oh my god!
See, it's not all hopeless.
I wish I shared your optimism.
Doctor.
Doc, come in.
Are you there?
Vardy!
Hey, Doc.
Are you there?
Vardy!
Vardy, that'd be your face.
And I'm no longer alone.
Alex and Gordon have just arrived.
Hey, excuse you.
Oh, man, that's good news.
I almost gave you guys up for loss.
We're planning to set up a staging area for attack in the Citadel.
Gordon and Doc can head your way.
I want to get Dr. Kleiner somewhere safer.
Then I'll meet up with you.
I'll take all the help I can get.
Aw, crap.
Incoming!
Barney lives, right?
Okay, Gordon, you heard him.
I'll catch up with you as soon as I get Dr. Kleiner settled.
I thought you said you weren't going to leave me alone.
Oh, no.
Oh, not Lamar.
Go on, Gordon.
I'll take care of this.
Wait, but you said you wouldn't leave me alone anymore.
Gordon, take care of yourself out there.
Dr. Kleiner, there's really no time.
No, no.
She's around here someplace.
Okay, hold on.
We'll find you another pet head crab.
There are plenty to go around.
There's only one heady.
One heady.
Okay, take that.
Is she up here?
I kind of want to look for her too.
Ugh.
Dog, go with Gordon.
Dog is coming for you.
with me?
Oh, yeah, baby.
Okay, I'll take that.
Taking your supplies a little bit.
What's this?
Oh, Hula Lady?
I'll take that.
No!
Lamar!
Okay, I think dog is getting impatient a little bit, so...
We'll go.
Why?
Where are you?
Oh, wow.
Oh, nice.
Oh, sorry.
She didn't like my crowbar.
Oh, wow.
Rude.
I love you, dog.
Is there anything in here?
No, okay.
Not.
Okay.
I gotta start using this.
It's so easy to just press 3 and then like not even... Okay, I'm good.
All right.
To press 3 and not worry about the rest.
You're coming with me, right?
Uh, oh, oh, sick moves.
All right, so we have an uprising now, right?
And we got milk.
All right, you're kind of loud so um and also i get stuck okay
anti-citizen one
do i go through here oh yeah okay oh i don't like the music at all okay
wait so if i imagine if i hadn't even looked at that i would have missed the entire scene
why is the music So creepy.
What the heck is this?
A baby.
Oh!
What's that?
And then the briefcase!
G-man.
Wait, actually, I thought I was gonna go upstairs.
Why is it going here?
Wait, now I'm actually not sure.
In here?
Oh, here we go.
Bad timing to lose my power?
Did you see him?
Oh, okay.
This place looks familiar.
Where are they shooting from?
Are they shooting at me?
Well, those guys...
Are you friend?
You look like a friend.
Hey!
What's going on here?
Okay, friend.
We're fighting together.
I love this.
Gosh, we haven't been here in so long.
Alright, buddy.
I'm gonna keep you alive.
Excuse me.
Oh, what are all of these?
What the heck is going on?
Oh.
Yeah, Terry!
Tear it down!
Yeah!
Woohoo!
Gordon Freeman.
Higher.
Dr. Freeman?
We're coming with you.
With you here, Dr. Freeman, we can finally make some headway.
Follow Freeman as a achievement.
Send your squad to a location.
You got it.
Oh, so if I point, they go.
Oh!
That's awesome.
Come on, everybody.
everybody our squad look at we got the little team we got the team going hold on i'm looking around for any loot all right team let's see okay c is direct do we go back inside oh oh all right
team this way this isn't where i came from no don't forget to reload dr freeman Oh, okay.
A little backseat or...
Venceramos!
Okay, are they going to be saying that this whole time?
Oh, you're a friend?
Watch out for the hoppers!
They're everywhere!
I like that they're called hoppers.
Hey, you too!
What is...
Can I not shoot through the...
Oh, yeah, I can.
Okay.
Wait, but what are these?
Use the grabby gun?
What does it do?
Oh, they're mines?
I don't think I want the...
Oops.
How the hell do I get above there?
Oh, I think I gotta get rid of them, though, no?
Don't waste the hoppers, Dr. Freeman.
them against the combine oh but i need wait
you can replant them if you can get those hoppers up without setting them off you can plant them wherever you want them
oh uh what is that what is he doing uh maybe not the best spot wait what I'm so confused.
Maybe there.
No team.
Team.
Team, stay away from that guy.
Hit it.
All right, watch out, team.
Everybody a fine.
Nobody hurt.
I'm a little confused.
Wait, so I just replanted like that.
And now it's Renly?
Eh?
Green is good?
Oh, okay.
Okay, so that's a bad guy.
Ah, I see.
Okay, okay.
Okay, okay, okay.
Okay, sorry.
I had a bit of confusion.
We're fine now.
Wait.
We're not fine.
Everything's good.
Head grabs!
Oh!
Haha!
I got one!
What are you doing?
Are you gonna join us?
Nice.
Oh, you're switching weapons?
Okay.
Oh!
Wait, hold on.
I'm not done in here yet.
Okay.
Oh, that's not what I meant to do.
Uh...
Sorry, Doc.
Oh!
Hey, it's a good thing I changed the mister.
What's everybody shooting at?
Alright.
What is that?
Is he gone?
Oh,
nice.
Good to have team.
I was not paying attention.
I was looking at that thing over there and not at the tiny men that I don't care about anymore.
I'm just gonna switch back to my SMG for now.
Team, what the hell just happened?
Did we lose someone?
Did they get swapped out?
Were they gonna drop that though?
Like how he's just like, yeah, I'm shooting it.
Yes, that worked.
Like that!
Okay, I'm covering you.
Is this guy active?
Yes.
Oh, okay.
There's so much that I'm suddenly like...
There's so, so much everything has changed!
So much has... I feel like I'm playing Call of Duty all of a sudden.
Oh, I don't know that.
Wait, is that guy alive?
Are you alive?
Where am I going?
Here.
War has changed.
Okay.
I definitely pressed G.
And that's why I thought, um, you know...
See me!
Oh!
Was it me?
Did I do that?
Oh!
You good?
I got him.
No, no, no.
Never fear.
I got him.
I don't know.
Will guys come out from here?
Do we need to go in there?
No.
Okay.
There's more in here too.
stick here.
You're fine.
Don't worry about it.
Hello.
I'm fine.
I don't need it.
Nice throw.
Thank you.
Civil protection.
I feel like it's almost worse kind of having these guys.
Good job, you.
You did it.
Oh, my gosh.
These things will be the death of me, I swear.
I know they will be.
Wait, actually, where...
Oh, excuse me.
Where do we go?
In here?
No?
Let's check out in here.
Sorry, Freeman.
Sorry.
Excuse me.
I don't like the sounds.
Why are you doing in the corner?
Nobody puts baby in the corner.
You're fine.
Is there a door?
Ah, I see, I see.
Whoever just gifted me a membership, thank you.
P .S.
Hyman.
Hi.
Thanks for the super talk.
Thank you.
All right.
This is our...
Nope, you're fine.
actually maybe we shouldn't bring this guy in here maybe we shouldn't bring the mine in close corridors okay all right what
a team oh oh okay we're fine all right everybody i don't know what the hell that noise was i'm a little scared good idea You think?
What are these?
What are these, like, blocks?
Oh.
I don't like this.
Hold on.
I'm letting my battery recover.
Oh, that's not my surprise.
There we go.
Yeah!
In order to be true to our nature And our destiny We must aspire to break our cradle It is
Feels good Her melon
Delicious This is time for summer Anybody want to sip?
Sip?
A taste?
Sorry Sorry, sorry I guess we really didn't need to come up here Let's go It's kind of useless.
Anything in the tub?
Oh, we're opening doors by ourselves.
Oh my god.
We're opening doors by ourselves.
That's fine.
Oof.
Okay.
Everybody's good?
We really didn't need to come up here.
It was just for spooky scary.
Hmm.
Okay, um...
Uh...
Oh no, wait, I thought I reloaded...
Or I thought I had saved downstairs, my bad.
Okay.
I think we need our medic, man, so we're gonna...
We're gonna...
Okay, we're gonna do this.
Alright.
And I'm gonna be in charge of grenades.
I'm gonna be in charge of these.
Okay.
I'm in charge.
What is that?
Oh, it's just a piece of something.
Okay.
We're good now, team.
Good job.
Is there anything over here?
Who's moaning?
Which one of you is moaning behind me?
Is it my butt?
Oh, wait.
I hear a guy.
Team!
Hello?
Are you okay?
Are you fine?
Um...
Oh.
You're luckier than that guy.
We'll just let them do their thing.
Dr. Freeman, I'm coming with you.
Ah!
Yes!
I think it's Medkit.
I'm fine, I'm fine.
Wait, did we have- did you leave that guy to join us?
Oh, did he die?
No way!
Why is his body like that all of a sudden?
Okay, I'm sorry.
I'm getting... Okay, I want to go in there, but I want to look around here a little bit first before we do so.
I don't know if there was anything else.
In fact, maybe just keep the grab gun out.
Um, does it...
Oh, actually, it doesn't seem like...
Wait.
Yeah, I don't think we can jump over there, Camel.
Oh, wait.
We can go this way.
No?
Behind you!
Oh, just...
Okay.
Sorry.
So sorry.
Excuse me.
So so sorry.
I'm sorry.
It's pretty spooky in here.
I'm not gonna lie, team.
I'm a little afraid.
These look like coffins.
Did I kill a guy?
I think I killed a head crab and I didn't realize.
I heard this the faintest...
And let me get out of your way.
Yeah, but where is it?
I heard him though.
I heard a little...
Oh well.
Okay.
It was Lamar.
Let's go up.
I think they're in there.
Hitting the gut!
Oh no!
Can I use any of this?
Don't get...
...
Don't, don't get hit.
Excuse me, please.
Please.
Take my shoddy back out.
Wait, excuse me, please.
Okay, thank you.
Is there one more guy?
Oh, I don't need that.
Where are they?
They're being freaks in the bathroom.
Don't forget to reload, Dr. Freeman.
Oh my goodness.
you what would i do without you
uh take that all right this is this is getting so there's so much so many places i can go you know so i'm getting a little overwhelmed just a time oh just kidding well you know what i mean don't forget to load please don't forget to go sorry yeah you should be how am i Wait!
Alright, I think I need to go down over here.
Oh my god.
Are we the squad?
Is there anything else in here?
Okay, sorry.
Excuse me.
No, excuse me.
Oh, no, excuse me.
What's in here?
It's such a...
This is a PT bathroom.
Oh!
I got more arrows!
That's awesome!
Okay, for the crossbow.
You missed the watermelons.
They'll be fine.
They look really refreshing, though, no?
Hey, hey.
Wait, is this thing going to attack us?
Wait, who?
Is this thing attacking us?
I can't...
I don't know.
Yes?
Okay.
Did we lose some people?
Feels like maybe we did.
Oh no.
Just kidding.
They're still coming down.
Oh, I got one.
Okay.
I think we're good.
Music is so loud.
These guys are...
Oh, uh...
Oh my goodness.
Hey.
Thank you.
I have to wait until somebody comes out, I think.
That's what I have to do.
Stay
low, Dr. Freeman.
I...
Okay, I'm not that low.
I see the room over here.
Oh my gosh.
This way.
Team.
Team this way.
Holy.
Uh.
Uh, team.
Team.
In here.
Yeah, team.
Are you coming or not?
Okay.
Oh my goodness.
How did that go?
Why was that guy even up there?
It's like waiting for us for real.
Yeah, that's what I'm trying to say.
I think we're all still here.
I think we're all good.
Take this medk!
Ooh, supply room.
Let's go.
Uh-oh, they gave us a lot of stuff.
I wonder why.
Okay.
Let me get out of your way.
Yeah, you should.
Yeah.
Okay, team.
Here.
You got it.
Actually, down there.
Sure thing, Gordon.
Oh, you go first.
You go first.
Let's go.
Ladies first.
Sorry, Doctor.
Where's the rest of...
Oh, we could have used this door the whole time?
We could have used this door the whole time?
Okay.
Come on.
Here goes nothing.
Let's go.
I want to take all their stuff, though.
Hey, everybody.
Follow Freeman.
Oh, yep.
Oh, my God.
I guess we...
From here we...
From here?
The way to go is...
Oh,
I see that.
This way, this way.
Oh.
Alright, team!
Close the gate.
Oh.
Will they keep coming in?
Maybe.
Whoops.
No, okay.
It's probably fine.
I...
I missed so many of those.
Oh!
Fool.
Noise.
Excuse me.
Goodness gracious.
Oh my goodness.
You know what?
I was also gonna look in this room.
Okay.
Just barely enough.
Sorry, Freeman.
You're fine.
Everybody's fine here, except that guy.
Ripperoni.
We go up or down?
Let's go up first.
Don't go up?
Let's check down.
I got jump scared.
I should have expected it.
Did you guys see that?
Did you guys see how bad I got?
Oh, I did not mean to save.
But that's fine.
It's fine, actually.
Holy moly.
They got me good.
They really got me good.
Before we go this way, I do actually want to check upstairs.
I think there's something good.
I just gotta...
Wait, did I put it back up right?
Oh.
No way!
Okay, it was a trap.
Sorry, Doc.
They're fine.
That was a trap.
Okay, I'm stuck.
I'm actually stuck.
okay we're going downstairs everybody please okay okay now troll turret boo okay all right sorry doc if you were so sorry you'd move okay thank you
excuse me excuse me excuse me excuse me excuse me oh that's just Okay.
I'm almost out of bullets on this thing.
Everyone, we're fine?
I think I hear another.
Or I can't tell their footsteps and my team's footsteps anymore.
Oh, nice.
Excuse me.
I have tried the alt fire for this one.
Yes, it is.
The ball.
I think I don't know how to use it very...
Here comes...
Oh!
Oh wait.
Sorry.
I was trying to get it.
Where did it go?
I hear it.
I'll grab it.
Oh, good job?
Wait.
Sorry.
We're fine.
...
Oh my gosh, I don't have... I'm not that low!
I thought that was a bone.
Just peeled clean.
One of them died.
One of my guys died?
Oh, was it my fault?
Oh, he looks peaceful.
He looks peaceful.
Let me get out of your way.
Honestly, surprise, it took this long.
We'll get more guys, though, right?
Team.
Wait, did they not trust me anymore?
I'm pressing C.
Did they not want to hang out with me anymore?
Yeah, team, come on.
Wait, why am I only down to two?
What happened to the...
Wait, did I lose two guys?
I thought I just lost one.
Lay it on, Freeman.
Uh-uh.
He ran?
Sorry, Doc.
He left?
Sometimes they get lost.
Oh, there he is.
Come on.
Let's get moving.
Yeah, what were you doing?
Come on.
Take this med kit.
Everybody take a med kit.
That was weird.
Okay.
That's a turret.
A couple turrets.
Oh, here.
I think there might be head crab people in there.
Okay, you guys stay here.
Like, stay over there, actually.
Whatever you say.
Yeah.
Okay.
No, no.
No, you stay there.
Whatever you say.
Yeah.
All clear.
Nice glasses.
Nope, follow me.
But...
Okay.
Oh, no.
Yeah, I...
Okay, there might be spookies in here.
See him?
might be spookies in here, so be careful.
I'm scared.
Okay, I knew it.
Oh!
Let's go this way first.
Wait, wait.
Let's turn around.
I'm scared.
Turn around, turn around.
Team, that was way too scary.
I'm gonna stay and hold down this way.
Wait, we lost somebody again.
Who did we lose?
Is she in there?
Oh, no, wait, I can't get back up.
No!
Wait!
No, I lost.
Did she get...
Did she get lost?
I lost to the load screen.
No!
That's so unfair!
Wait, if I reload...
Nope.
Dang.
Oh, that sucks.
Wait, so what's up here?
If anything.
Just...
Just, uh...
just the symbol and some supplies
sorry I can't believe we lost somebody I hate using the grab gun on these because I can never tell if I get the stuff or not okay I guess I didn't need it ah
excuse me I'm so bummed about her getting eaten by the load screen I'm not gonna lie I'm really bummed about that.
That's so scary looking.
Look how freaky this is.
Oh.
What?
Why is it my...
I tried to...
Screenshot.
Didn't work.
Oh well.
Oh, she's back!
Oh my gosh!
Oh my gosh, she's back!
We didn't lose her!
Thank you so much for the tangente, thank you.
Oh, she's back.
Yay!
I could kill one guy on accident, but, you know, she was a...
If she died too bugged, that's even worse.
Uh-oh.
Oh.
Hey, it's Freeman.
You're not leaving without me.
He's back!
It's like we never even lost him.
Oh, this place.
Are there gonna be a bunch of zombies in here?
Oh.
Come here.
Come
on.
Trying to grab them.
Trying to hit them against each other, but I'm not aiming very well.
Come here.
Oh.
Good job, Tim.
Mmm, soup.
I did say it right.
Hackers.
Oh, gosh, there's so many of them.
Ah, I'm trying to help, Tim.
I promise.
I'm
trying to help team, I promise.
I'm doing
my...
Everybody alive?
Yeah.
Good job, team.
Okay.
Onwards.
Forward.
No zombies, right?
I think I need to go to the other side.
I think I saw it, yeah.
Oh.
Thank you.
Let's even the odds a little.
Yeah!
Let's go, baby.
Let's go.
Sorry, Freeman.
Oh, you're good.
Let's even the odds a little.
I agree.
Let's swoop.
Oh, actually, do I go through here?
Oh, not yet.
Sorry.
No, you're fine.
They're so polite.
Oh, I go around here.
Oh, how the hell?
Where did you come from?
How'd you do that?
Up and over?
Uh-oh, wait.
I love following the free bit.
I'll follow you.
You know where you're going, right?
Yes!
Do I need to go out?
I know where I'm going.
Oh, yes, I do.
Why do I have a feeling I'm going to get ambushed all by myself?
I'm going to be the only one on this side.
Oh, wait.
Actually, team...
Oh, I think I'm stupid.
I think I fall right here.
Okay.
Over the gate!
There you go.
Irish
Rist Watch.
Welcome to membership.
Thank you!
Over the gate!
This game suddenly feels like multiplayer with you guys, you know?
That's a must!
I'm covering.
Oh, no!
I got you.
Don't worry.
I covered you.
Oh, no.
I can't see anything.
Oh, golly.
Golly.
Why did I...
I'm sorry.
Why did you die?
Wait, I could prevent his death.
I could prevent his death.
I thought these would explode.
But they didn't at all.
Oh, now they do.
Now they do.
Now they choose to explode.
Is there anybody even over there?
I can't tell at all.
Ah!
Sorry.
I'm so mad at myself.
I did not.
I meant to press.
And my finger slipped.
Damn it.
Darn it.
Ah!
Oh well.
Okay.
There we go.
We have two left.
We lost another.
Where are they?
Okay.
Will that work?
No.
Blame.
That's some pretty serious music happening.
All of a sudden.
Wait, why?
Why?
What happened?
How did we lose another guy?
Wait, what's that?
Where is my guy?
Where's my last guy?
It's all me, I think.
I couldn't see anything.
I didn't know what they were shooting with.
They were just...
Tiny little men!
Oh well.
I couldn't tell they were shooting with these guys.
I'm gonna plant some charges and blow this open.
Okay!
Where's my other guy then?
Okay, I have a feeling I'm gonna need this.
Oh!
Stand back!
Thank you!
It's like that dinosaur game.
I'm here.
Where are you?
Oh, hello.
We've lost someone.
I don't know where they are.
I think I gotta go.
No, you're fine.
I think I gotta go back.
I think I have to go back and find my guy.
One for me and one for Mimi.
He's back at the start.
I don't think we're gonna get ambushed anymore.
So let me go check this room again.
I guess.
Where the heck?
They're expendable.
No, they're my team.
Oh.
Hello.
Sure thing, Gordon.
Stay away from the fire.
I'm going to stay and hold down this spot.
You're going to come in, right?
Oops.
Whoops.
I think she's stupid.
Maybe we don't need her.
No, no.
Don't go backwards.
Go forwards.
Here we go.
No, don't go that far forwards.
Go in here.
Okay, we got her.
Okay.
Alright.
She might be stupid, but she's my stupid.
The luckiest stuck NPC.
What do you mean by that?
Like us.
Yeah, lucky for her, I like stupid, so...
They go in here.
That door's locked from the other side, Dr. Freeman.
Maybe you can find a way around.
Okay.
We'll go through here.
Looks nasty in there.
Good thing you've got that suit.
Oh, you guys can't crawl?
Oh, I have to go find a way around for you all?
What's that sound?
I don't like that at all.
It's like radiation.
Oh!
It absolutely is radiation.
It's not like radiation.
It is!
Yeah, they're not coming, are they?
Wait, I just went through all that effort to save her.
To save her ass.
okay what's the best is this sinking oh my gosh oh my gosh
oh these again haven't seen this in a while uh
okay oh golly guys this is
There's much...
Wait, I need this thing, too.
What am I thinking?
No, sideways.
I need you sideways.
Wait, no, I need you sideways.
Oh,
I wish I could rotate.
Wait, maybe if I...
No!
Don't leave me?
Don't leave.
Ah!
Alright, nice.
My mind.
might be a genius and we're just gonna grab this wait i just realized
i just realized i need i need my hands what does that go to okay i'm just gonna kobe oh
um Good
to know, these guys are just chilling in here.
I almost jumped on that.
I thought it was fine for a second.
Oh, gosh.
Um.
Okay.
I hear a lot of growling, I think.
Oh.
No.
Stop!
Gravity
gun works on headcraft.
in the body oh my goodness gracious oh my goodness gracious where even do i go over yonder and they're throwing at me
don't forget to reload mr freeman
okay i almost fell in at one point too i don't know which i think i'll try this way I hope I don't have to redo this part but if I do I do maybe I should save just in case I don't have much health though
Mint on a rampage
Yeah I'm a highly trained professional I could have used this too I saw it and was just like if I start That's me on the right I was like If I start getting ambushed, I'll use that.
And guess what I didn't do?
Oh!
I'm gonna switch to my shotgun, I think, and then I'll...
I'm going to attempt...
Oh my gosh.
No.
I tried to jump.
Oh my god, no!
I jumped!
That's okay.
I'm more prepared this time.
Maybe.
Oops.
Try another.
Oh, I see the head crab literally walking.
Oops.
Well, um...
Okay, let's once again switch to my shotgun.
There we go.
How prepared, though.
I don't think I'm very prepared.
I'm not good at...
I don't know why I'm...
Not good at jumping!
and running!
Oh, no, no, no!
Oh, just kill me.
I'll redo it.
Why?
Okay.
That's fine.
Oh, I got it stuck on the wall.
Perfect.
Okay.
Just run instead?
Okay, I'll try just running.
Oh.
Okay.
Okay, just running.
Just running.
Oh, shoot!
Ow!
Ouch.
I didn't, um, oops.
You shouldn't have done that.
Why did I do that?
We're fine.
Everything's fine.
Don't worry about it.
Well, we're in much better shape than before.
We're in much better shape than last time, so...
I'll take it.
even though I miss we mess up but we still take our win
I was able to slice and dice one guy that was really cool I liked that
I did quick save right I'll just do it again
no no
we save scumming
okay I
can't tell if he's got a head or not.
No head.
Oh, I hear him.
Oh, I hear them.
Come on.
A little closer.
I want her to get a little closer.
Okay.
I want to get over there.
I hate this goop.
I hate this.
I hate this part.
Look how cool it looks, though, with him behind the headlights.
It looks really good.
He's a little shy.
Yeah, he's not coming over.
Come here.
What are you doing all the way back there?
He's having a little bit of trouble, a wee bit.
We'll ignore him for now.
Oh, no.
Oh, no, no, no!
Um, okay, I think I need to reload.
Okay.
Ah!
He's
on his way now!
I don't have much shotgun ammo left.
Okay.
All right, good stuff.
Okay, all right.
One moment, please.
Okay, I'm assuming...
Actually, I don't...
I'm trying to see if I can figure out...
I guess just over there is where I need to go.
Can you do the move?
I hate this!
Oh my gosh.
One step forward, five steps back.
Nearly, nearly there.
Oh, really?
Oh, this is still water.
Okay, hold on.
Now that I know that, I couldn't see.
I thought it was land.
That was my bad.
Don't do that.
Don't be like that.
Come on, baby girl.
Okay, there we go.
Honestly, save.
Right!
I see it now.
I see it now extremely clearly.
Okay.
I made it to the other side.
And, um...
Uh...
Do I go up?
Now what?
Right.
Bad timing.
Let's check out the other area too.
We don't need to go immediately into the first hole we see, no?
I'm cautious of head crabs.
Okay.
So delicate.
All right.
I think we should pick the last one.
Does it even matter?
Get my gun ready.
Oh.
Get through the toxic tunnel under city 17.
Okay.
I did that.
And now we go open up for our friends.
Okay.
hey game that was not very cute i didn't like that at all i don't think i like that part i don't think i like that very much hey it's me open the door hello i see you made it through okay figured you would barely oh my gosh barely why don't you know how to crawl also come here come come come come you got it yeah yeah come on come on Come on,
everybody!
It's just the two of you!
Everybody, they say!
Wait, this is not a real door?
Oh, um...
Sorry.
Me too, I'm lost.
Wait, huh?
Wait, what?
Was there another door?
Just the two of us.
We can make it.
Ah!
My bad.
Okay, squad.
Surely we'll get another guy.
Like, now.
Uh, actually, what do I want to use for these guys?
I'm just going to use the grab.
We're fine.
I didn't want to waste ammo on them, you know?
They kind of suck.
No stragglers?
They were fast, yeah.
Holy moly.
Okay, um...
Let's have this gun ready.
Whoops.
Oh!
Friend!
Dr. Freeman?
Yes!
You were looking for a place to hold up.
It's not safe here anymore.
They're shelling the hell out of us.
Keep moving, Dr. Freeman.
I'll send word you're coming and see you up ahead.
Okay, don't die!
I'm still moving.
Wait, uh...
Yeah.
I'm ready.
Nice shot, thank you.
Did it.
My last bullet took him out.
That person was on fire, yeah.
Maybe I could have saved them if I was faster.
Sucks.
I'm also back to being low on health.
Oh no!
I am.
I pressed it literally before you said anything.
What's in here?
Oh, okay, that's where we need to go.
But those are our friends.
Oh my god.
Are they our friends?
Actually, I can't tell.
Are you our friends?
They are not friends.
They're not friends.
And don't look at them.
Don't look at them.
Oh, look at them.
Oh, thank you.
Or not.
not but I
don't know if this is gonna help us for the future doing this I don't know not really okay then let's go I was like oh maybe they'll be gone from the area you know not really but it's fun to shoot things hello someone's sad in Oh.
Everything good?
Oh, you got watermelon in here though.
What are you complaining about?
I love the tub gun.
I'm
leading.
I'm leading.
Are you gonna follow?
It's Freeman!
Follow me!
Yeah, yeah!
Casually walked in front of me.
It's so normal.
There we
go.
Oh, I'm sorry.
Sorry, sorry.
I tried.
Whoa.
Goodness.
Where are you?
I don't want to go in there.
just wait hold on there was more stuff you know what actually let's just go in there
wait um okay here we go we're
helping the squad oh gosh his eyes scared me
ah okay come across i think i think they killed me but the
I think they killed me with the drawbridge!
I think that's how I died!
Excuse me.
Ignore, ignore?
This place is crazy looking now.
Actually, where... where am I?
Oh, here we go.
Uh-oh.
Head crabs?
About?
Should they drop the drawbridge, I'll be for real.
Let's switch to this.
Oh my gosh.
Oh
my gosh!
Take this medkit.
Fakes!
Holy!
Not quite as funny as if Alex had landed on your head.
Still a big dead boss.
Imagine being the resistant soldier who killed Freeman by dropping a bridge.
Gosh!
Oh.
The game sometimes rewards you.
For being a little adventurous.
Is he dead?
Wait, should I even be going down there?
Oh, he's dead.
Okay, good.
Oh, my goodness.
Yeah, we just noped him right out of there.
I feel like my reflexes are...
questionable but sometimes they're pretty good watch out for the fire don't touch it oh don't touch the fire everybody zombies are they down there uh oh we did get uh some more shotgun ammo which is good good
Zombies!
Not plural.
We're good?
We're good, maybe?
The zombies!
Oh, okay.
That is- Sorry, Doc.
You're fine.
Where's our other team?
We are missing one person.
Oh, come on again!
It's fine, I suppose.
Never forget, oh, reliable.
Probar, my beloved.
Wait, hold on.
Let me reload.
I don't want to get ambushed.
What is going on out there?
Okay, uh, switch to this.
So this is here.
This is back a circle.
You assholes!
You're trying to kill me!
The zone claims another.
Okay, I'm guessing that they're probably, they respawn.
They're like unlimited here.
So I'm gonna save and we're gonna run for it.
Oh my gosh, I don't actually really know where to go now.
Everyone's fighting everyone now.
It's crazy!
It's getting crazy in here!
Oh!
Be careful.
Dr. Freeman, I'm coming with you!
Oh, okay!
Awesome!
Look at this!
Oh my gosh.
Ah!
He wasn't fast enough, dang it!
That was my fault.
I tried to grab it.
Ah!
Where did I last load?
I think okay hold on I'm gonna reload I'm gonna reload because we were right here
I remember there's head crabs in here
and there's head crabs somewhere there okay with our future knowledge we have we have done a better job with our foresight
Ouch!
Go, go!
Okay.
Dr. Freeman, I'm coming with you!
Oh, it's a lady this time!
Oh, the reload was so worth it.
Um, don't, don't, don't just, don't just hit, take that.
Okay.
Let me get out of here.
Maybe he'll throw one.
No?
I don't even know if I'm hitting it.
Oh, nice.
Someone got him.
Okay.
Don't forget to reload, Dr. Freeman.
Oh!
I'm almost out.
Oh, actually, I probably should.
We'll switch to the SMG old...
A second old reliable.
Okay.
Alright.
Where do we go?
This?
Aha!
Oh, they're below two?
We didn't lose a guy, did we?
I think we have to go down anyway.
Okay.
Good job, team.
Good job team?
Somehow we lost someone.
I don't know how.
That's fine.
Good job, Mito.
Thank you!
Actually, if they're this close...
Oh!
Before he could...
Throw the grenade.
I saw him reaching for it.
Be careful here.
If we
lose somebody!
Out!
Me too!
Just keep fighting!
Oh my gosh.
Holy moly.
Are you kidding me right now?
Did you die?
Why did you get him?
This is insanity.
We lost someone else?
Oh gosh.
Okay.
Don't worry about these guys!
Sorry, Doc.
Yeah, where are my ant lion?
Oh, well there's no sand around, that's why.
Wait, why did we come up here then?
Oh, there's stairs.
What the?
Wait, is this guy dead?
No, wait.
Yeah.
Wait.
Oh, oh, I thought it was a mutated one.
Where's our full team?
What happened to them?
Okay, so did we come up here for no reason?
Oh, wait, there's over here.
I think we came up here for no reason.
That kind of sucks.
Oh, oh, it's a big circle.
Oh, no, wait.
Ouch, ouch, yeah, you should be.
Oh, can I go down?
Did I miss something?
Oh, we dropped down in here!
I see, I see, I see, I see.
My bad.
Oh, yeah.
I can't go, though.
Oh, I don't have any.
Are there any guys down here?
Actually, I can't tell.
Oh, team, we're here?
Okay.
The overkill.
I thought there was, like, a bunch of them running at me.
That's why I did that.
Wait, I hear more.
I think they're fighting each other.
Let them fight.
I don't know where.
Excuse me.
Hmm.
Okay.
It's like the Walking Dead.
I can't get enough of these zombies, baby.
I'm sorry, Freeman.
Sorry.
I don't want to risk touching the fire.
I can't
stop touching the fire.
Can I open this?
No?
Open this?
Oh, there's...
Okay.
Wait, what do I have?
What do I have with that?
Okay, let's just put this back on.
all right ups we go
oh i heard buggy sound no more people no more team
it's not even they're not even like also i know this is like so late i'm just gonna move myself just a teeny tiny bit
Squad said you got this.
It's really quiet.
They're shooting at zombies.
The void between levels has taken them.
Wait, really?
Or is it...
Are they actually supposed to be here?
Squad following.
Anything you say, Doc?
Stop yelling at me!
I'm a careful player.
If you don't like how I play, then you can leave.
Oh, they're back!
They're back!
So it was bugged.
See, it's a good thing that I didn't just keep moving.
Oh my gosh.
Whoa!
Wait.
Oh wait, is that Alex?
Girl!
Actually, now I can't tell.
Oh, it was Alex.
I had a feeling I'd find you here.
I've got Dr. Kleiner in a safe spot.
Now we can join up with Barney.
There's a command center downstairs.
I'm hoping to find information about generator locations.
Ready?
Let's go.
No, no, no, I'm not ready.
No, no, no, your turret!
Your turret did a little bit of damage to me, Alex.
Wait, do we can see Barney?
Dr. Freakman doesn't need a hero.
She's a highly trained professional.
Let's go, baby!
Whoa.
You got them good.
I don't know why I keep trying.
Wait, why is there more healing down there?
Kind of crazy?
Cover you.
Oh, okay.
They're from everywhere, though.
Oh my gosh!
I hope you're okay!
I think we lost a guy.
He's not okay.
Is that our guy?
No, that's not our guy.
Oh, that's our guy.
Well, maybe move when there's a grenade.
Excuse me.
Oh, I heard their footsteps!
I heard them!
I heard them.
They're big old footsteps.
You'd better reload.
Yeah, actually, I was just about to say.
Oh, now Alex is doing it too.
Everybody's back seizing me.
Okay, not yet.
Anything?
Washing machine?
Let me get out of your way.
Yes, please.
She says that she gets in my way.
I love them for that.
I love when they're stupid.
Now I have my own harem.
You notice that?
Let's go.
Communal bathroom?
Oh, you're right.
It was, wasn't it?
Nice.
Pardon me.
Wait.
Whoa, it's just the onsen, everybody.
It's just Sento.
It's fine.
Co-op bathroom.
to see it i took way too many hits then i should excuse me gordon yeah yeah excuse alex
okay this is it you take that door i'll take this one ready when you are oh this one okay hold on let me let me what should we what should we use i have one alt okay hold on here we go
I was one guy Well, we're in luck There's a generator in the square outside We're trying to disable as many as we can To loosen the Combine's grip on this sector It'll take me a few minutes to expose the core Then I'll need you to hit it with a burst from the gravity gun In the meantime,
watch my back You were amazing back there, Dr. Freeman But I feel sorry for anyone who put down a security deposit Let's go.
Okay.
Let's go!
Okay, so wait.
I go to...
What?
And I gravity gun?
Who?
This thing?
The generator.
What's the generator look like, though?
I guess we'll see.
I guess we shall find out.
This way?
Which way are we going?
Oh.
Okay.
Wait, it's right here.
Oh.
Sauce.
Hurry.
Oh my gosh.
Okay.
Oh no.
As soon as the generator's down, I'll open that gate and we can get out of here.
Okay.
Wait, as soon as, what gate is down?
There's a gate and it'll be down and then I go.
Right?
Okay.
Sorry.
What is this thing?
Oh, it's one of these guys.
Oh.
Where are they?
Dang, I was too late.
Is this part gonna be- is it this gate?
Is this part really annoying?
Up right, up right, up right.
I'm wasting them.
Oh my gosh, wait, they're really coming from every side.
Oh!
I'm stuck on the wall.
Ow!
Shoot!
Where?
Oh, there it is.
There goes the external shield.
Oh my god, no.
My shot!
Thank you!
So sweet.
Babies, aren't they?
And okay, I give up.
This is not good for here.
Oh my gosh.
Oh
my god, there's so much happening.
Oh, there's a thing here.
I hear them coming though.
Oh, that's it.
This thing?
What do I do?
Okay.
Alright.
Holy cow.
Oh my god, there's so many men.
What do you want me to do with it?
You should be on the far side of that.
There used to be a bridge here.
Let me see if I can scout a new path.
Ah, wait for me here.
Wait, do I have to wait?
Because there's, like, supplies down there, you know?
Do I have to wait?
There might be health.
Oh, Alex, I'm not doing so well.
Don't forget to reload, Dr. Freeman.
Me going in with my...
With my, uh...
How do you zoom again without...
Looks like we might be able to get through down there.
I'm not gonna make it.
I'm not gonna make it, I can tell you that.
Oh my god, his health!
I'm gonna do like a hard save instead of an auto save.
Oh here!
I'm sure there's more health in here, right?
I hear them.
Oh, what the heck?
Wait.
Wait, how?
Maybe...
Oh, I'm stupid.
There we go.
Surely there's more health in here.
Yeah, I heard you.
Which one's coming?
Oh, gosh.
Soup.
Out.
That is
not soup.
For art commissioning purposes, what color is your
Does Mint know how to one-shot manhacks with one attack off of the gravity gun?
I don't.
Yeah, I do have a reference sheet.
Um, if you're so curious, you can check that.
Yes.
We've seen a Mint Snake cosplayer.
But when will we have a Gordon Freeman cosplay based on the thumbnail?
Oh, hi, Kira.
I feel like...
Sorry, I'm gonna keep...
Actually, at this point, I think the auto-save...
Has me with the quicksave...
Where, like, the quick-save would be, you know?
So...
Um...
I, uh...
Really just need some health right now.
Oh, I see.
I have to go up this way.
Can I get through here?
Does it need to be...
Whoa, my gosh, I almost just blew myself up.
That would have been crazy.
And also not the first time I've done this.
Come on.
You can do it.
There we go.
Oh, did I just one-shot them?
Somehow.
Somehow I did that.
Caught the second or third time as well.
Hey, hey, wait a second.
My brain gets bigger, the bigger my glasses are, okay?
I think I've only done it once today.
If you do it against a close wall, they one-shot.
Ah, okay.
I was trying to hit them and make them hit each other, but that seems way easier.
I have six?
Okay, here we go.
Oh my gosh.
They're like destroying everything in there.
Wow.
There's more guys.
No, my friends!
What have happened to you?
There's so much death in this game.
Wait, there's a lot actually.
Wait, there's a lot going on here.
Why is this open?
It's kind of mysterious.
Whoa.
I didn't expect people!
I didn't expect company!
Oh my gosh, I hear, I hear Zombos, I hear men.
Okay, wait, let's, let's, let's, I was going to check out this way anyway, so.
Ah, it's just some health.
I mean, not just some health.
Like, that's huge.
We need this.
But, I mean, it's not like the, I mean, it's very obvious the other way we need to go, but.
This place is spooky.
I know, I don't like it very much.
I keep saving because I'm scared.
Oh, that's where we came from.
Oh, I'm hearing the pipes.
I kind of like the audio clues that they give you a little bit.
Like, you're supposed to use the pipes so they make sure you hear the pipes kind of way.
I'm a scaredy ghost.
Where'd that guy go?
Where'd he go?
Don't tell me the zombie got him.
No way.
Are they shooting the Zombos?
Oh, now they're shooting the Zombos.
Sometimes I can't see the crosshairs.
I don't hear him anymore.
Oh, wait.
I think that was them.
Is it Z?
Ah, yeah.
I think that was them down there.
The Zombo.
They took care of it for me.
Easy.
Easy, easy.
that was dirty that was dirty what did I pick up oh nice my leg oh good thing we got that health huh is it gonna do it again
rude rude rude rude
we're fine we're fine Maybe.
I actually have no confidence, but, you know.
Gosh, this is another really long chapter, huh?
What if I fall down down?
What would happen?
Okay.
Nothing, apparently.
Now, can I...
I can.
I don't like this, though.
I don't like this one bit.
Oh, okay, I thought it was going to be, like, a really long hallway, you know?
Hopefully he hit whatever he was aiming at.
Come
back?
Was that supposed to be a puzzle?
I don't think so.
It was too easy.
Like, what else are you supposed to do?
Oh!
Oh no, no, no.
Let them handle it.
Oh shit, you son of a...
Oh, I almost died.
Morphine administered.
Thank you.
Please, um...
How much better am I gonna get, Doc?
99.
Okay, not so bad.
Oh!
I don't like this.
Not a singular bit.
Oh my gosh.
What are you chopping on?
I see rope.
I think he got one of the guys.
That's funny.
Here he comes.
His little tongue.
Oh, there's another one there, too.
There we go.
Goodness gracious.
There's his head.
I probably should have used this.
Use the ropes to cross pits?
How even?
What's down here?
I did save, right?
Oh, my God.
Just a man!
I don't think he even
I was going to say I don't think he even noticed me.
Like he did, but he definitely was too stunned to speak.
Aww.
The hell are these crickets?
Oh my goodness.
Wait, how do I...
I guess we'll do that.
Come on, pull.
Sorry, buddy.
Crowbar will take care of it.
I liked my plan better.
better I liked my plan better the
crickets are taking me out oh but they're all dead wait they have they they're so cute actually oh look he's got one big tooth nobody laughed the crickets are so loud I liked your plan better me too Snaggle Tooth.
Just like me!
Ah, you gotta see my tooth on this?
One tooth.
Where the?
Where did this guy come from?
Wait, actually, where did you...
Where did you come from?
What should I use to kill these things?
I'm glad you're feeling better thank you pistol that's what I thought I like don't want to waste my ammo on them you know this guy I'll leave alone I don't care about the crickets CQC rocket launcher yeah okay
where your respirator now why would they recommend that looks like that guy got squished yeah bye yeah bye oh my gosh like yeah bye does he see me yeah bye oh
not tasting See?
Wait, come here!
Yabai, yabai do!
Come here, come here!
Come here!
We're just gonna have a nice, pretty little, um...
pile of zombos.
Oh!
Oh shoot.
Is he dead?
No, he's still moving.
Oh my gosh.
There we go.
Who are you?
Come here.
Hi.
Come up here.
Yeah, boy.
You're tough.
it hurts are you okay come here come here come here come here come here come here um oh my gosh i just saw that guy over there too
so i need to get to the other side why did the minke cross the road
Okay, I'm gonna save if I die, I die.
I just wanna see what's going on down here.
Ouch.
Okay.
It's a tactical something, or whatever.
Okay, wait, now I'm lost.
Wait, now I'm like...
Oh, I hate these guys.
Wait, that's not what I'm going to do.
I didn't mean to use that.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
We're jukein' them?
I think I got all of them.
Oh.
Just kidding.
Tactical reconnaissance mission.
Maybe I should just go for it, though.
I've already made it this far.
What the hell?
Oh.
That's awkward.
I just lightly tapped.
them a little.
Oh, wait.
There's nothing here, though.
It's just all...
It's just, uh...
Stuff.
What's it called?
Supplies.
Mario reference?
Yeah, totally.
Okay.
We'll save.
This might be stupid.
This might be dumb.
They're so stupid.
They just leap wherever.
What if I...
Gordon hit them.
Oh.
They're so cute, though.
Oh, I hear one of the poison ones.
Ladder to my left.
I don't want to waste all my ammo, so we're going to go for it.
I do not see.
That's okay.
Actually, oh, there's only like one guy left.
The way I can, bro?
Oh, I saw this, but...
Oh, I didn't realize it was a ladder.
Oh, okay.
Thank you.
I was just like...
I was like, it's very clearly something because it's lit up, but I couldn't tell what it was from behind.
On your right now.
Okay.
Ah, ha, ha!
We're on the other side!
We made it!
Easy peasy!
There was that one guy.
That's him.
I'm wasting ammo.
There we go.
It wasn't really Ravenholm, but it felt like it.
Not even.
It was just a tiny spooky.
Could have been much, much worse, I'd say.
What's in there?
How do I get in there?
It's kind of fun.
I want to crawl through the hole.
I say, and then maybe it'll be like my way to escape and I definitely don't want to crawl through the hole.
Thank you.
What's in this?
Whoa, heavy.
Is YouTube being sad?
Okay.
A big Lego.
Yeah, probably explosives, right?
That I could like throw at.
This
is a big health, but I'll take it anyway, I suppose.
Don't take his pillow.
Poor guy.
Okay.
All right, we're once again reconnaissance with my explosives, my exploding box.
Uh.
It's so quiet.
Who's gonna be in there?
Oh gosh, who's gonna be where?
Oh, I'm scared.
Okay, which way do I go?
Okay, I'm hearing the pipes again.
Oh, I see, I see.
I'm gonna be in there.
Maybe.
Keep your eyes open up here.
The way it's like so quiet, all you hear is the wind blowing.
It's really freaky.
I wonder if I could have stopped that with my gravity gun.
So I don't think the box explodes.
I think the box is just a box.
But it was kind of heavy.
Which one's the magnum?
Where are you, my babies?
Oh, revolver.
I'm stupid.
So sorry.
I was thinking of...
I don't know what I was thinking.
Prospo might be tricky.
I only have 10.
Let's try the revolve.
I only have 12.
12 shots.
Can I make it?
Wait.
Uh-huh.
Ew.
That was dirty, wasn't it?
That was so dirty.
I thought I saw eyes.
Okay, luckily not.
They are giving me crossbows.
I wish it was unlimited.
Oh, look, they gave me a revolver ammo too though.
Let's go.
Maybe the crossbow would be better here.
Or actually, I can't see.
Oh.
Ahoy!
He dodged into it.
I knew he would.
I don't like the flammable thing there.
Oh, yeah, the explosive barrel feels like a trap.
That's what I'm saying.
Okay, I keep saving.
I keep saving.
Okay, goodbye full health and full.
We're just gonna hold on to it.
Wait, actually?
Wait, what do I do here?
Oh, wait.
Don't I need to...
I'm ready for you.
I'm not ready.
I'm actually scared.
I'm scared.
Don't ambush me, please.
I'm just a ghost.
Oh
perfect How much How much How much longer Where
Well Guess I could have been worse for me That is it right Okay good
First try First try
Ooh, green room.
Ooh.
What else can we grab?
Okay, nothing.
Aha.
Oh, my gosh.
Where are you?
Can
I kill you guys?
Wait, oh, wait, wait,
wait.
Holy moly.
I couldn't do anything.
The crossbow probably would have been better there, yeah.
Uh-oh.
Oh, wait.
Do I need to walk on this?
There's no way.
There's health down there.
Think, Minky?
Well, I thought maybe I would have to reactivate.
it but like to have it move again look around you'll find it really a wheel a wheel
walking the rail was a good idea okay it's not electrified oh okay good
Oh my god.
They're trying to smush me.
Wait, I'm in the opposite position now.
I can shoot them.
That's kind of fun.
Oh wait.
Oh, I see what I need to do.
Oh no, no, no, no, no, no.
When did I last load?
Threaded the needle.
When did I last save, I mean?
Oh!
When did I last save?
I don't want to wait for this thing again, though.
Wait, I think...
Okay, hold on.
I'm just going to reload and see what happens.
Where am I?
Oh, okay, okay.
This is actually fine, because then we know these guys come in on...
There were barrels... Oh, it's those barrels down there.
Okay, never mind.
They come in over here.
Okay.
This is fine.
It's exactly the mistake I made a few hours ago.
Now we're not, like, two hells.
We're not, like, to health.
We're fine.
Okay.
And then...
Oh, my gosh.
I don't know if I'll make it.
I might not make it.
Oh.
Wait, I forgot it's the slowest thing in history?
I might not make it.
Huh.
From where?
No, please!
Ah!
There's a ladder?
Where?
Even from the yellow part that looks like a bit of a high jump.
That's what I was thinking.
So I was like, wait a second.
Am I doing the right thing?
At the end of the catwalk on the other side.
Over there?
I see this line right here.
I see.
See it?
This one?
Ugh.
We all know Minto was ladder blind.
Yeah, they really need to be in brighter color.
They really need to be like purple or something.
To be fair though, I thought my plan...
Like made sense, you know?
Yes!
Okay, but since we're going through the ladder...
Wow!
Oh my gosh!
What the hell?!
I think ladders would be helpful.
Yeah, and they're cute!
Oops.
Oh,
that guy is still there.
That's funny.
Okay.
Alright.
Uh.
Ah!
I thought there was a...
Let me see it.
Let me see.
Okay.
Alright.
This is better than before.
Can I even get this guy?
Oh my god.
Because he's standing, I feel like...
I think he's like, uh...
What's it called?
Like, uh...
Awake.
Alive?
That's the word.
Alive.
Now he can't bother us anymore.
Death!
Hello.
Fine.
I got an achievement for looking at this guy.
Alright.
And then we drop down, right?
Wait, what's this?
Is that a head?
Oh, nope, that's more ammo.
Always welcome, baby!
Okay, now we drop down.
Uh, wait, what do I... we want this.
Maybe.
Yeah.
Okay.
Oh, and I knew it was there.
I remember seeing it before too.
I remember seeing it last time when I tried to jump from here.
Wait, it's green, though.
It's not green.
I've never seen anyone die to that hopper before.
I didn't die!
First of all, that's...
That's...
That's inaccurate.
I reloaded.
whoa my friends we got split up by snipers and he's pinned down on a warehouse up ahead go ahead he's relying on you oh barney i'm on my way we got a team again
i almost killed them
oh shoot
Oh my god.
You're Barney's old friend, aren't you?
Yeah.
Maybe you can help him.
Sniper's trapped him up on that warehouse roof.
He was going for a cache of grenades, but I doubt he can get to them now.
Warehouse roof.
Go on, Dr. Freeman.
Lead on, Freeman.
Okay.
I'm not quite sure where to go.
Okay, so not here.
Ouch.
Ouch, ouch, ouch.
Ouch, ouch.
Oh my god.
Everybody is dying.
Warehouse.
One second.
Oh, there we go.
Nice.
I have one grenade left.
Oh, my allies are dead.
This is 100% a first try.
Don't even...
Don't even pretend.
What warehouse roof are we talking about?
Is it supposed to be obvious?
Am I silly?
I think I'll save anyway, even though I have no people.
Yeah,
yeah, run, run as fast as you can.
You can't catch me.
I'm the Minter Red Man.
From where though?
Oh, jeez.
Oh,
jeez.
Oh, jeez.
Mr. I'm scared.
This is a scary area.
Scary.
Wow, jeez.
I'm scared.
Surprise, spooky.
I might be the most...
Ah!
Cracked sniper there is ever.
This is what I become when I'm terrified.
When I'm scared, okay?
I become cracked.
It's life or death.
I'm already dead.
I will take that.
urinal where do you poop oh is that a urinal actually i don't know
surprise spooky is the least favorite thing ever barney somebody up there barney somebody up there wait who's who's yelling
Is that, are you always, yeah, are you, are you playing dead?
Wait, was that, could he not swim?
Help me!
Oh, hello.
Help, help me!
We thought we'd be safer down here.
Little we know the place was infested.
The rest of them headed upstairs.
It took the chance for the snipers.
I guess they're still up there.
Oh my gosh.
Oh no.
Oh.
Oh my god!
I'm gonna go through all my ammo here.
Sorry, I just shot you on accident.
You still alive?
How do I save him?
Are you gonna come with me or you hurt?
You're relaxing.
What are we doing here?
I didn't kill him, he's blinking.
This guy's alive and well.
On your feet.
He's alive!
He's moving!
He'll get over it.
Confested, huh?
What is this?
Amnesia?
I've never played that game.
Wait, actually, is there anything in here?
Ew.
X marks.
Oh, there we go.
Oh, Jesus.
Don't like these guys at all.
They scare me.
Lying down injured guy.
We'll remember that.
Taking a peek?
What's going on in here?
We gotta head to the roof.
Party!
Oh, I see some guy.
Oh, nice!
Oh,
come on.
Nice.
Oh, okay, is that unlimited grenades?
Wait, is that party?
Barney!
It's Barney right there!
Okay, wait, before we see Barney, I am curious what's in here.
Curious and terrified.
Oh my gosh, I didn't need to go downstairs.
Oh, this is where I came from.
Okay, if it's a grenade battle they want It's a grenade battle they'll get The doors were locked Oh, okay I didn't realize Oh, I don't think I even tried them, so
Okay, one moment, please One moment, please Okay, gosh, this is such a long chapter too
Fight it, fight it
where is it coming from oh and there okay let's see if I can reach all right shoot shoot me first try I
can't even believe it myself over here hi Gordon I can't move these snipers got me pinned down Gordon lava couple grenades that'll clear him out okay I did.
Did you see that, Barney?
You would have been so proud of me.
Where does this one come from, though?
That's what I'm not sure of.
How many are there?
I guess if we go upstairs, we'll know.
Oh my god.
Open
windows?
What the heck was that?
bird up here?
Aha!
I see, I see.
Okay.
I think that is a...
Head crab, no.
Oh, no, they are birds!
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, you shuffle them feet.
Okay.
We gotta scare him off.
I think I was too high.
Dang it.
I'll never recreate what we had before, guys.
Okay, I got him.
We got that guy.
Nice.
Two down?
I'll never recreate it.
It was the coolest I'll ever...
It's the coolest I'll ever be!
Now this one...
Not quite sure.
I am quite sure.
Oh, oh, oh.
Spam, don't you guys.
Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Maybe he got it.
No.
Why can't you aim, Mr.
Ay, ay, ay, ay, ay, blah, blah, blah, blah.
Over here.
How am I supposed to...
Ay, ay, yeah.
Where?
Barney, why didn't you take care of these headcrows?
Oh my gosh, he was right behind me!
He was hiding too!
Oh my goodness!
How can I get closer?
Ow!
Gordon, take out these snipers, would you?
I'm trying!
Okay.
There we go.
All right, thanks, Gordon.
Oh.
Wait, I didn't do that.
I was switching my gun.
Okay.
I almost want to restart because I lost so much health trying to run from it.
Barney.
Barney, did you see how cool I was?
Barney praised me.
Barney!
Barney, tell them, tell me I was cool!
Oh, this way, okay.
Over here!
I didn't know where you going, okay.
Let me get this gate.
My civil protection status still gives me limited clearance.
Did you hear a cat just now?
A cat?
That damn thing haunts me.
Where?
What?
What are we?
Look out for what?
Okay.
Oh,
the cat.
Oh, the...
Okay, Barney.
Which Barney is this?
Which Barney?
Oh,
it's gone.
Barney, I'm scared.
Anytime I hear something flying around, I have deep trauma.
It kind of looked like that, actually.
The thing that caused my deep trauma.
I hear people talking.
Anything else?
Ouch, oops.
Oh, my bad.
Okay, we're fine.
Whoa, where'd you guys come from?
Ouch, ouch.
Cover!
You fuckers!
What
did you shoot?
Did I get it?
One more try.
More try.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, my aim is so bad.
Team.
Team, don't rely on me.
Someone else take the grab gun.
Team.
Someone else.
Oh my god, let's use a grenade.
Barney.
I'm not trying to sacrifice you.
Goodness, great.
Wow, there's a lot of stuff here.
There's an old building up ahead, a basement museum or something like that.
Whatever the hell it used to be, now it's a nexus for Overwatch in City 17.
It's the main source of pain for this part of town, thanks to a huge suppression device.
It's raining down hell from the roof of that place.
Okay.
Sorry, Doc.
Sorry.
Are you hearing someone talking?
Like a doctor or a scientist?
There it is.
The Overwatch Nexus.
Looks like they're mobilizing big time.
You can sort of see the gate from here.
I'll show you when we get to street level.
Okay.
We'll have to get in that building to open the gate.
Even then, the suppression device will suppress anyone coming through unless we shut it down.
Then let's go.
Okay.
Oh, he's got it.
I hear a turret.
So much for stealth.
Was that
me?
No, I couldn't have been.
Oh my gosh.
What the hell?
Me?
Oh.
Okay, that's fine.
There's that gate I was telling you about.
We'll have to come back here after we get it open.
If we get it open.
First, we gotta get into the Nexus building.
Okay.
Oh, I don't know what I'm doing!
You're not gonna hurt that thing from down here, Gordon.
We'll have to shut it down from inside.
Oh my gosh, how did I live?
I gotta save anyway.
Um, this time.
Oh my gosh, okay.
Ow, I just took- I took down from that.
Cal here?
Oh, that's the wrong gun.
That's not a gun at all.
Oh my gosh.
Did it make my license?
Thank you for the raid.
Would it
be worth to use something else?
Well, I have two all-time.
So let's just keep running.
Everybody in?
Oh, we just lost somebody?
Uh-oh, why are you giving me more turrets?
Why are they giving me turrets, Barney?
Ducky, thanks for the gifted!
Phil, thanks for the gifted!
Thanks for the five gifted, thank you, duck girl!
Rip... riperoni?
Just a little bit.
Oh wait.
There's nothing here.
Oh, these are just guns.
I can't see at all.
I thought they were the little turrets.
Turret things, you know?
Why is there just a cage here?
Those glasses aren't helping.
You might be right.
I'm honest.
honestly am more grateful that it's not um what i thought it was because uh because because because because i don't want to do another tower defense again all right let's go
yeah pardon me yeah sorry bring it on
barney okay nothing up there you better reload okay i'd like to take a moment to address you directly dr. Freeman yes I'm talking to you the so-called one free man I have a question for you how could you have thrown it all away it staggers the mind he's talking to me do we just go through the no there is no front door did you guys see a door let me get out of your way this is not a scientific revolution you've sparked this is death and finality
How old are you?
This is, yeah.
Um, wait.
Oh, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Ha ha ha ha.
I got it, I got it.
I'm a pretty smart lady.
Oh.
How long is this chapter?
Barney, buddy, we're gonna need you to start hitting your shots.
Real though.
Do we have anything I can throw?
Soup?
I don't think that'll help.
I don't think soup will help.
Where's Glyzo?
Gladly, gladly, glad.
Okay, that's a lot.
They're like, hey, do you need every single grenade ever?
Okay, what are you trying to tell me, huh?
Huh, game?
If I get hurt from this, I'm blaming the game.
Did it do anything?
No.
A new chapter started right before Barney.
Wait.
Did it?
These are strapped to the floor.
Uh-oh.
Turrets.
Hey, you've got the HEV suit.
you deal with them then i'll work the security console what do you think i'm doing
no i didn't see it what was it called
the previous was anti-citizen something and this is called follow freeman ah i didn't notice wait barney i need you to get away from that barney sorry doc no you're you're doing Everything gone.
Wait.
You can roll grenades.
I can?
How?
Right click.
Will that do anything?
Oh.
Those wires just activate the turret?
Is it?
I can't tell if they're exploding ones or not.
Well, I saved.
It's fine.
Let me get out of your way.
how did you miss
okay I think it worked better when I was like crouching
oh wait
I was a little what are you doing
roll a grenade in there if you've got one that ought to do it oh there we go i think it actually went in this time great i'll open this up okay i was like it was going too hard before and bounce it against the wall
balls.
Sorry, Barney.
Barney, Barney, Bar.
Barney!
Uh-oh.
Dropships.
What's that mean?
They'll be coming from the roof.
No!
If we want to get through these shields, we'll have to take out the generators one at a time.
Ah!
Oh my gosh.
Don't forget to reload, Dr. Freeman.
I just did, okay?
I thought I saw a guy.
Alright, so we...
Oh, it was that.
That was glowing.
Um...
The generators.
One by one.
Okay, I guess that's our first spot we have to go to.
Pain!
Okay, okay.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, wait.
Oh, wait, no.
How am I supposed to get it now?
Excuse me.
Oh, wait, do I not have any more grenades?
What happened?
Wait, what happened to all my grenades?
Uh, what just happened?
What actually just happened?
I didn't resupply?
Am I stupid?
Oh no, wait, I thought I totally did!
Oops.
Let's go.
I'm not gonna save, because that would be silly.
Be careful, team.
Hey!
Let us out of here!
Oh!
More team!
Hey, I'm screaming!
Let's follow him!
I love you, man!
Okay, now I'll save.
Finally.
Yeah, we're... Yeah, we're doing really well for ourselves, guys.
Yeah!
Okay, um...
Let's even the odds a little.
Okay, uh...
Okay.
No!
Why did you do that?
I think we just lost a man.
No, we didn't.
We're about to.
No, no.
Let's go back downstairs, guys.
Here, have a med kit.
Oh, thank you.
I think someone else needs one.
What was that?
Okay, please.
Stay here.
You got it, Doc.
Yeah.
Stay down there.
No anything you say stay down there whatever you say stay down there Stay sure thing Gordon no stay stay don't follow me over here.
No, no don't go don't come up here Here goes stay yeah, there you go.
There you go.
There you go No, okay there you go
Barney you are not an exception
You don't get to come up here!
Alright, what I'm going to try and do is...
I don't know.
Okay, we got one.
It says only...
Oh, maybe we did lose one because...
Okay, I think we did...
Maybe not.
I don't know, actually.
Okay.
Uh...
Other side!
Here, patch yourself up!
Okay, good job, team.
What am I even holding?
Oh, nice.
We've got three generators to disable.
Might as well start with this one.
Yep.
Hey, you've got Eli's gravity gun.
Try giving those generators a jolt.
See if you can shake them up a bit.
This?
Man, Overwatch owns the roof.
And that's where we're at.
Oh, just like that.
Okay.
Two more generators to go.
Okay!
Watch out, team.
Team, I'm scared.
I'm scared for us.
Oh!
Oh,
Barney, I almost killed you.
For real.
Oh my god!
Ah!
Were you pointing that at Barney?
Why are you doing that for?
He doesn't trust you, I think.
I'm gonna reload.
Anybody else?
Oh.
Reload, Dr. Freeman.
I'm going to take this.
Thank you.
Okay, cool.
Everybody is alive.
Alive and well is another question.
But alive at the very...
Oh, this is a circle.
Okay.
Alright, let's try this way.
Don't!
No!
Stay!
Here goes nothing.
Yeah, there you go.
There you go.
Now where are they at?
Okay.
Oh my goodness.
Are you at least taking cover?
Barney!
Ha ha ha ha ha!
Sorry, Barney.
Um.
The room is the worst in the entire game.
What?
This one?
Oh my gosh, it's not stopping.
Anyway.
Okay.
Let's not do that.
Please, excuse me.
Wow.
With that much security, there must be something good in there.
Go for it, Doc.
I'll wait here till you shut it down.
What are you?
What do you mean?
Go for it!
What do you mean by that?
Dr. Freeman?
Excuse me!
That's not the one we got, right?
That's a different one?
Oh, there's this one too!
Ah.
Sorry, Freeman.
I see, I see, I see.
Okay.
Save often?
It's instant death if you fail in that room.
Okay.
Thank you for the warning.
I'm gonna see what happens if I go through it.
Okay.
Now we know?
What happened?
That wasn't me, right?
Don't freak me out like that.
Can I sneak under here?
Let's try it.
I warned you before, please don't spam!
Oh my goodness.
Why, why, why?
Okay.
Uh, wanna figure out where I go to next?
Hmm.
You don't
remember this chapter at all.
Maybe you blocked it from your memory.
So painful.
Yeah, I'm trying to figure out where I can, wait, oh, maybe the pipe somehow.
How do I get up there?
Can I grab this?
I already had the gravity gun.
No.
Again.
It
looks like I could jump on these ledges, but I cannot.
To go forward, you must go backward.
I see.
That's a good hint.
Thank you.
Wait?
Ah-ha-ha-ha!
Okay.
Oh, look at that!
Why do they supply those to me?
Creepy!
Creepy.
If the glass has gotten bigger.
Hey everybody.
You're welcome.
I did all the hard work.
Wait.
Is that the thing that Alex's dad was in?
Or am I crazy?
It's the interloper.
It looks like thighs.
I kind of see it.
Let's get in here, team.
I think they're coming.
Team, they're coming!
Ouch, ouch, ouch!
Wait, I can't get you!
Oh my god, he died.
No way!
You better
reload.
Did we lose...
No, we just lost one guy.
Didn't even work.
I don't like the alt of this thing because I don't know how to use it.
Well that kinda sucked.
Wait, how am I...
Do I...
Oh, there it is.
Woo!
That was close.
One generator to go!
You bounce it around and hope it hits something.
It's good in small rooms.
That's why I tried it right there.
Oh well.
Well...
It's fine, we got it done.
Can I disable this thing?
No?
I thought with the generator disabled, it would disable.
Oh, I was gonna say, why did it multiply?
Oh, it's just always three of them.
Oh my gosh, we just lost another guy.
Oh, we lost all our guys.
No!
Oh, it's so bad.
It's so bad, Barney.
It's just you and me, Barney.
You and me against the world, Barney.
It's so over.
This is still good, right?
Maybe I should have saved before I tested it.
You and me, Barney.
You and me against all of them.
We can do it together, Barney.
Just the two of us.
Not gonna reload?
Nah, I like living on the edge.
We can make it if we try.
Just the two of us.
You and I.
Okay, one way.
I'm not gonna save.
If we live through this, I'll save.
I hear a turret.
Oh my gosh, I thought you were from...
No, no, no, no, no, you can't throw a grenade at me, I threw a grenade at you!
Okay, so we didn't live.
Oh wait, we had already defeated these guys.
Oops.
She said oops at the same time.
It's Barney stream now.
Barney has such plot armor.
It's not fair, but I'm also happy about it.
Here, the ambush is tough.
The ambush is tough.
Okay, hold on.
Thank you.
Thanks for the med kit.
Stop!
I have my grenades!
Where?
What?
Who else?
An attempt was made.
There was.
We have one more guy than before.
Take this med kit.
Oh, and he healed me!
Actually, I can heal here too.
Wait!
The gang's all here!
Let's go!
Wait!
Come on!
Everything's good!
The gang's all here, baby!
Okay.
I'm going to...
Ah!
Save right here.
Okay.
And then they start coming in.
And there's a turret.
in here.
And they're also coming for us, so we gotta be careful.
Yeah, behind us.
I think we should handle these guys first.
Good job.
Okay, team.
Good job, team.
Yeah, hunker down in there.
Yeah, pretty much.
Okay.
All right.
What are these?
More grenades.
Oh!
Huge!
They start coming and I don't stop coming.
One more generator.
Yeah, we're on the last one.
We're on the last one.
I did save, right?
Okay.
I'm not sure what I hear beeping.
It's making me nervous.
I
don't like the looks of this either.
Where are you?
Oh my gosh, they're just running and shooting.
Wait, this is so stupid.
Stop running!
Are you guys just running?
I love Barney.
I hear you.
Set some traps for them, Gordon.
Um, my...
Me, I'm the trap.
My arm.
Well, I wasted the first one.
So...
No!
In the end, it all worked out.
It doesn't matter how I did it.
worked out still i'm wasted i thought this was the beep ah it worked out
okay if it works it works exactly you're a trapping though because i would fall for you get this sorry get get this corny out of here
Also, sorry if I haven't been hearing donals because the game is so loud and I haven't turned down so much.
But, Rishi, thank you, boo, thank you, Dr. Hushanonikas, oh my goodness, thank you.
Oh.
You guys stay there.
Let's go!
Yeah.
Good, good, good.
Didn't
light up that part.
That's gross!
I don't know how to get this one though.
Hide on the right?
No, this one will definitely see me.
I don't think I can pre-throw because I think the grenade has to go inside.
Run up, roll, and size.
Ah!
Oh!
I think we're all gonna die.
We're all gonna die, team.
We're gonna die, team.
Don't run into it.
We are very unconventional here, huh?
It's fine.
If it works, it works.
Oh, Yuki and Yuna!
Thank you so much for the return, Rektaeku!
My name is Mint Phantom.
I'm playing Half-Life 2.
It's a little stressful.
We're fine.
We're doing it.
Okay, did I save?
Shut down the suppression device by disabling its generators!
That will shut down the suppressor on the roof as well.
Okay, nice.
What is that?
Let's head for the roof now, Gordon.
Whatever you say, Barney.
Where's the roof?
How do I get to the roof?
Oh, okay.
It's like something.
Licks up the Barney!
Oh my gosh!
Holy moly.
Um, hold on.
I'm gonna go heal.
This way, Gordon.
Nope.
No.
No, hold on.
Reload, Dr. Freeman.
Oh!
Thank you.
See you, Roncha!
Thank you so much for the 10 gifted!
You vaporized like three guys.
Yeah, I...
That was a good part to use it, right?
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, oh my gosh!
Come on, Gordon!
You told me to look out!
That's what I'm doing!
I'm trying!
Hold on!
Is there gonna be a boss fight on the roof?
Oh yeah, yeah, there will be.
Yeah, yeah, there's a boss fight on the roof.
There's a boss fight on the roof.
holy cow oh okay we're gonna use the crossbow got it oh my gosh Barney I get it please takes the med kit sorry Freeman no you're fine that's so smart okay
let's head for the roof now Gordon there's our gate let me just get it open dr. Freeman wait we'll come with you I'm gonna stay here and keep these gates open long enough to make a difference go on up and connect the sky bridge we need to let reinforcements go through from every possible direction i haven't heard that in a long time see you when i see you gordon see you when i see you barney
that's a crater thank you so much for the five good thank you what is that
Sorry, Doc.
You ran in front of me!
Ha ha ha ha ha ha.
Oh, I see it.
Hmm.
Uh...
How can I get the...
I think I gotta be fast.
Ow!
I'm not very fast.
I saw their shadows coming down.
That was neat.
Here, catch yourself up.
I guess this is...
They gave me a crossbow, but they also gave me this.
Oh, not yet.
Not yet.
Got too ahead of myself.
A bit.
I was reloading.
You cover me.
Oh, oh, that really sucked.
That was not good.
What are you doing standing in the corner?
Me too though.
I'm also scared.
Where's the rocket at?
Rocket's at the start?
Oh, thank you.
Ah, I see, I see.
Thank
you!
Got it, but they're still shooting.
I lost everybody Oh my goodness
Why not because I have them now Oh I don't think that worked
Maybe this is why The crossbow is going Another Another Oh, I got him.
Somehow.
I'm actually not sure where to go, so I'm, like, kind of running around.
A little bit.
I'm a little scared.
Is that a guy?
Oh, no, this is the drop bridge, right?
That's what's open.
The sky bridge?
Nice.
Oh, I have more people!
Where did you go from?
The squad!
Thank
you.
We tanked it?
Reload, Dr. Freeman.
Alright.
Don't worry about the guys downstairs.
You're fine.
Holy moly.
Fantastic.
Oh, it's quiet.
It's Bito, let's follow her!
Leroy, Binky!
Is your middle name Rambo?
What can I say?
I'm not dead.
In the game.
You wanna know how I became a ghost.
Did you shut off the suppressor and open the gate?
Make this medicine.
Thank you.
squeeze we drop the crate of rockets coming across the plaza if you can make it there you should have everything you need to take down these striders follow Freeman follow Freeman
are we gonna get going soon oh excuse me I need to just take a second you don't know what I've been through
Okay, so where am I going?
Striders are seven hits on easy.
Wait.
Oh, I'm here.
Oh, my gosh.
It's so loud, and this is not a good spot that it, like, loads me at.
Ouch.
Oh, my gosh.
I'm trying to get to the sewer tube.
I'm just going to run for it.
Holy!
Okay, maybe if I stay here for a second, they won't notice me and then I can run.
Where is it?
Oh no, oh I did hit him!
Phew!
Oh,
and now he's gone.
Oh no.
But I still don't know where the rocket box is.
Push forward?
Like in here?
Wait, what do you guys mean?
Push forward.
Across the plaza.
Gotta go deeper.
Okay, I'm gonna save.
Deeper.
Okay, I got three.
Wait, is this a turn?
No way.
Are there guys here now too?
Unfortunately, no.
Oh, it's gone already.
Oh my gosh, how many are there?
How many striders are there?
Two, it looked like three to me.
I'll believe you guys.
Oh, that sucks.
Oh, that really sucks.
He ducked.
Yeah, I tried to get him, but he ducked.
Look at it.
Will anything else hurt them?
Or is it just...
I mean, I saved.
Oh, well.
It's kind of trouble.
any explosives so these guys too but these also I gotta get kind of close
like oh no oh
wait the center has the okay we'll go to the center I'm just trying to get out actually you know what let me Well, no, I'm not gonna reload.
I don't remember where I saved.
I'll just hold the grenades.
That was so bad.
Okay, I think this was right before I left, so...
You're going the wrong way!
What do you mean?
You said the center!
Is this not the center right here?
Do I need to go this way?
Huh?
LRB?
G?
No?
Straightforward is the center.
And I'm so confused what you guys are...
Oh my gosh!
Don't jump at the pit, I'm not trying to!
I'm trying to get to the pit!
What the?
Yeah, that guy is like kind of smoking, though.
Maybe we hit this guy.
Like, he's kind of...
I think we'll be able to get him.
Maybe there's something over here.
If I'm lucky, no.
Go straight.
Okay.
I will try.
Oh
my god, no!
Tivo!
Oh, that's messed up.
I just got here.
I think he's aggroed a little bit.
I think that was one down.
Okay.
It's always better to focus on one and then go to the next, you know?
Yippee!
That's it?
I told you there were three.
My health is at 10.
I need to be able to get back into the base.
I need to be able to get back into that little crevice.
Uh, I did save.
I did save.
Okay, but now we know one comes from over here.
So we run, run, run, run, run, as fast as we can.
Okay, so we're trying to get to the room?
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
Oh my gosh, oh my gosh.
I didn't know if he noticed me.
He did definitely notice me.
He knows I'm here.
He's camping.
Okay, okay, okay.
okay so we're going to somewhere unknown
oh is there another one oh my gosh no way wait i'm so confused actually now okay so those are those will just keep coming but now i need to get to somewhere i need to go to a direction.
What?
I need to leave the area.
Yeah, but which way?
Do I need to go over that way?
Other side of the bunker.
Okay, okay.
Aw, man.
I wish another guy hadn't...
Oh, whoopsie.
I wish another guy hadn't spawned.
Yeah, I know I need to try over there, right?
I'm just trying to die.
Die to this guy!
Oh my gosh.
In the direction you came from at the start of the chapter.
I- Oh, gosh.
Oh, no way.
Hi, I'm so sorry for you.
Are there two of them now?
This might not be a great place to...
Oh, you're a friend.
I'm trying to get in!
Ouch!
Wait, um...
I'm lost!
I'm last!
Because you need to blow up that.
Huh?
Spy crate not helping.
Okay, so this opened up for me?
Yeah, uh-oh.
Uh-oh, what?
Why is this part so confusing?
Why?
Why am I not...
Why do I not know what to do at all?
Kill the Striders, but won't they come back again?
Or these ones, because I'm finally progressing, they won't.
They actually are?
Ow!
Oh,
this part's brutal.
This part's really hard.
Why do I start with my...
Cobra Blar.
Last time he was like, wait for me!
This time he didn't make it.
So sad.
So if they are finite, I will take care of...
I will work on taking them down.
I suppose.
Oh my goodness.
This part's a little stressful.
Wow.
It's part a little bit stressful.
He got me and I got him at the same time.
I need to kill them for my own sanity.
I don't care if I don't have to.
They're stressing me hell out.
Because I don't know where to go.
They're stressing me out because I'm lost and also getting attacked!
Wait, did I not shoot that?
I think I got hit and I didn't even shoot that rocket.
Unless he shot it down, I'm not sure.
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
I don't like this.
I don't like this at all.
I don't like it.
I'm so stressed.
Did I get him?
Okay.
Okay, please.
Now where do I go?
Okay, some people said follow the road, so I will try that, but there's guys shooting at me here too.
Actually, I'm just gonna save.
I don't care if my health is so low.
Okay.
Ah!
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Okay, okay, okay.
Okay.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Gosh, I really wish there were, uh, what's it called here.
A, um...
A sniper?
I'm not doing
it.
Yeah, it's not good.
You can rocket them?
I guess that would be, you know, a pretty fun...
Let's try it.
Oops.
Why is there, like, no splash damage on this thing?
I tried crossbowing earlier, but...
That's why.
That's why I haven't been using it.
Ah!
Yeah, they dodge like crazy.
Did I get hit again?
This is empty, right?
Unfortunately.
Unfortunately!
It was so close.
I feel like crossbow is my only answer.
There is health over there.
Okay, maybe it's clear.
I'm gonna hard save instead of a...
Instead of the quick save.
I do see health.
I wish I saw more health.
What are you guys doing?
2 HP in a dream.
Now 22 HP in a dream.
Is there anything in here?
No, just...
Just their little thingy.
Okay.
So we have to go down?
Is this all supplies?
Yippee!
Oh,
yes, baby!
I'm gonna hate this, aren't I?
I saw you.
Anything over here?
No?
Okie dokie.
from here.
In what sense?
Okay, I think we just gotta run.
Okay.
Just run.
Are you gonna compose I'm gonna make it.
Run until you find a crate.
Okay.
Alright.
Like, do I need ox power running?
Or are we, like, regular running?
Like, is this good?
I don't think it would be, but...
Ox power.
Okay.
Once I hear the crash, I'll start running.
Maximum Velocity.
Oh,
I passed it.
Too far?
There was an entrance on the left.
I don't
know what y'all?
What is that?
Combo's in here?
What is this thing?
What is this?
I should have killed the camera.
What's wrong with me?
Oh,
well.
We do a little bit of training here, yeah.
Don't run.
Don't do it.
Anything.
Oh my gosh.
Stop it.
Oh no, is that a buddy?
Oh my gosh.
Save, I just did.
Oh, I didn't realize.
I thought this was...
Oh, nice, nice, nice.
We take what we can get?
Oh!
Oh my gosh.
Gosh!
To my eyes!
All right.
Go away!
Please!
I don't want to get stick bugged!
I think I have to go up this, no?
I can't even see it.
Okay.
Alright, this is pretty good standing, I'd say.
Not so bad.
I did save, right?
Saving?
Okay, good.
This is evil.
Absolute evil.
Okay, understood.
What do I need to do?
Ow!
Oh my god!
This is where we found Barney.
Man, I'm stuck.
Wait, I'm actually stuck.
Okay, there's health down here.
There's quite a bit of health around here.
Where was the jerk?
There he is.
The jerk that tried shooting me.
Stop, please!
These guys are the worst things in existence.
Please, my god!
Get this guy.
Oh, shoot.
Okay, I at least got him.
Oh, no, no, no.
I need them to not be aggroed on me anymore.
Standing next to the barrels?
Me?
Oh, like saying, oh, you're standing next to the barrels.
If he hits you, you're gonna die.
We'll see what happens.
Are those my friends or please be friends?
Oh, there's barrels right there.
Oh, he was standing next to the barrel.
Okay.
Maybe.
I
kind of want to.
He's annoying.
It's quite annoying me.
Now I'm taller.
Oh my gosh.
If I leave, will these guys go away too?
If I go to the next part?
If I don't destroy the thing?
Oh, sorry.
Oh, I'm not sorry, actually.
Okay, I'm just gonna go then.
Oh!
Vicky, my show.
Nope, I hear it.
i hear it i hear it wait is it gone
it's a mess out there yeah i know this close to the citadel they've turned the streets over to striders i think we can push them back and we can just get to high ground okay almost to the citadel wall doc i don't know how the hell we're gonna breach it but you've made it this far i don't know don't make me don't make me say Hi!
You're a super smart scientist!
I think though guys...
Oh my gosh, I just realized the time.
I think I'm gonna call it here, actually.
I know.
How many more chapters do I have left?
Three?
I think.
I don't remember.
There's like one hour left of the game?
Oh, wow, we made really great progress then.
One or two hours.
That's enough for one more stream.
Yippee!
And even if it's a little longer, that's okay, too.
We will finish next week then.
Woohoo!
Wait, I did save, right?
And then I'll hard save.
Yeah.
Good stuff, good stuff, good stuff.
Yay!
We're so close then.
We're almost there.
Thank you guys for all your help.
I know I missed stuff.
And, um, but I appreciate you guys trying to, trying to direct me.
Hot dog!
I was just about to send you this to check in about the time.
Thank you, Duago.
No, I, uh, um, I was having fun, actually, even if it's a little stressful.
That's why I lost track of the time.
But I gotta be up early.
I gotta be energized for meet and greets tomorrow.
And then after my meet and greets, I want to play...
I want to play Delta, but...
I played kind of long today, though I want to play kind of long tomorrow.
If not tomorrow, then Sunday.
I'm on like the last hurdle of my cold.
Where I'm like still kind of, I don't feel so bad, but I'm still like all stuffed up and that sometimes gives me a headache.
You know, so I'm like on the last little bit, like just a little bit more rest, I'll be okay.
Either tomorrow or Sunday, I'll play more Delta because I want to just play as much as I can.
Takizawa, thank you.
So I probably will stream tomorrow regardless.
Just deciding what I want to do.
If I'm, yeah.
Thank you for the stream.
Oh my God, thank you so much for the pink.
Listen more to your voice for fantastic reality.
You sound really good.
Given the things you have to push, throughout the time.
I'm an extra awe.
Thank you.
Resting glitch face.
Thank you for the vibe, Genta.
Thank you.
Thank you guys so, so much.
And I will see you guys when I see you next.
Otsu Min-to.
And we will beat Half-Life 2 next time.
Bye-bye.
See you when I see you.
Party!
Fake me, thank you!
Bye bye!